LEADING A GOSPEL CHOIR IN YOUR
BACK YARD.
DON'T TRY TO GIVE HIM MONEY OR
HIS THOUGHTS AND MORSELS OF
STALE BREAD COMPANY ESCAPE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP TECHNICALLY
CONTROLS THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE WHEN IT COMES TO THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL HE SEEMS TO
RESERVE HIS OVERSIGHT FOR
TWITTER.
HE TWEETED WHAT IS TAKING SO
LONG ON THE INSPECTOR GENERAL'S
REPORT ON CRICKET HILLARY AND
SLIPPERY JAMES COMEY?
HERE ARE -- THEY ARE SO MANY
HORRIBLE THINGS TO TELL THE
PUBLIC, THEY HAVE A RIGHT TO
KNOW.
AT TRANSPARENCY.
WHICH RAISES THE QUESTION, WHERE
SEEN IT AND WHAT COULD BE IN IT?
BYRON, WHAT DO WE KNOW ABOUT
THIS REPORT?
>> IT APPEARS IT WILL BE DELAYED
AGAIN.
THE SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
HAD SCHEDULED A HEARING FOR
TODAY WHERE THEY WERE SUPPOSED
TO TALK ABOUT IT.
THAT GOT DELAYED UNTIL NEXT
MONDAY THE 11TH AND NOW WE ARE
HEARING IT MIGHT BE DELAYED
BEYOND THAT.
THE REASONS, FEET ARE BEING
DRAGGED SOMEWHERE IN THIS
PROCESS, THERE IS A HANGUP WITH
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION AND
PERHAPS THE MOST INTRIGUING AND
AT LEAST THE LAST MONTH OR SIX
WEEKS, THE INSPECTOR GENERAL HAS
GOTTEN NEW INFORMATION AND
ACTUALLY INTERVIEWING PEOPLE.
I DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THAT'S
ABOUT BUT IT'S AN INVESTIGATION
THAT IS GOING ON.
>> Tucker: WHAT DO WE KNOW
ABOUT THE CONTENT SO FAR?
>> IT WILL BE PROBABLY CLOSE TO
500 PAGES AND YOU CAN EXPECT
DISCUSSION ON MANY TOPICS.
WE EXPECT DISCUSSION ABOUT THAT
LORETTA LYNCH-BILL CLINTON
MEETING ON THE TARMAC IN
ARIZONA.
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL HAS LOOKED
INTO THAT A LOT.
EXPECT A LOT OF DISCUSSION ON
JAMES COMEY'S DECISION TO DRAFT
AND EXONERATE A MEMO, AND I
EXPECT A LOT OF DISCUSSION ON
WHETHER COMEY WAS TRYING TO
AFFECT THE OUTCOME OF THE
ELECTION ON SEPTEMBER 28TH, IN
WHICH HE REOPENED THE
INVESTIGATION.
THE DEMOCRATS SPECIFICALLY
WANTED THE INSPECTOR GENERAL TO
LOOK INTO THAT.
AND, THAT WAS THE REASON THAT
COMEY REOPENED THE INVESTIGATION
BUT WHAT THEY FOUND OUT WAS THAT
McCABE KNEW ABOUT IT MUCH
EARLIER IN OCTOBER.
JUST A COUPLE MORE THINGS, LOOK
FOR THE DISCUSSION OF THE
STATEMENT ON JULY 5TH AND
201616, SAYING THAT
HILLARY CLINTON WOULDN'T BE
CHARGED.
LOOK INTO WHY LORETTA LYNCH DID
NOT APPOINT A SPECIAL COUNSEL TO
LOOK INTO THIS, AND WHY ANDREW
McCABE IT TOOK SO LONG TO
RECUSE HIMSELF.
REMEMBER HIS WIFE HAD GOTTEN A
HUGE CLINTON RELATED
CONTRIBUTION?
THE LAST THING, THE THING WE
HAVE HEARD OF THE MOST ABOUT
WITCHES McCABE VERSUS COMEY ON
THIS LEAKING THING.
McCABE SAYS, YOU TOLD ME IT
WAS OKAY TO LEAVE AND COMEY SAID
IT, NO I DIDN'T.
WE'VE ALREADY GOTTEN A LOT
THROUGH PROFESSIONAL RESPONSES.
>> APPARENTLY WE HAVE READ THAT
HE COMMITTED PERJURY WERE LIED
TO FEDERAL AGENTS IN THE COURSE
OF INVESTIGATION.
THAT WOULD BE FOR CIVILIANS A
FELONY.
IN THAT CASE WILL HE BE CHARGED?
>> WE DON'T KNOW, THERE HAS BEEN
A CRIMINAL REFERRAL TO LOOK INTO
THIS AND BY THE WAY, HAS NOW
BEEN REPORTED THAT McCABE WAS
INVITED TO TESTIFY AT THIS
JUDICIARY COMMUNITY AND HE HAS
ASKED FOR IMMUNITY IN EXCHANGE
FOR HIS TESTIMONY.
IF HE DOESN'T GET IT, HE WOULD
HAVE TO TAKE THE FIFTH
AMENDMENT.
SO YOU ARE UNLIKELY TO SEE AND
SAY ANYTHING.
CLEARLY, HE IS CONCERNED ABOUT
CRIMINAL EXPOSURE FROM WHATEVER
IS IN THIS REPORT.
>> Tucker: 500 PAGES.